so leute vom wegen nordpol hier wohnt
der weihnachtsmann
wer begehrt einlass ja lasst sie
quatschen reden dabei erfahren was los
was ist passiert die zahlenkolonnen
hochgegangen ja ja und schon ist der
weihnachtsmann sozusagen arbeitslos
warum lässt man sich nicht raus
weihnachtsmann ja es wurden so viele
kinder auf mich zugelaufen weißt du was
ich habe den vorschlag für dich ich gehe
jetzt auf dem weihnachtsmarkt und welt
für mich kämpfen wenn du nicht gehen
darfst dann dürfen die leute jetzt auch
nicht mehr vom weihnachtsmarkt die sonne
verschwinden okay
so fertig ach du scheiße
weihnachtsmarkt hamburg das geht gar
nicht 3g läuft draußen frei vorm und 2g
darf im gehege säulen steht
jetzt man sagen hier und das heißt ihr
geht jetzt nach hause ihr habt jeder
schon drei glühwein gemacht wird es
langsam schluss ja ok mindestsätze
machen wir das
wenn du sagst dann machen wir das noch
mal richtig wenn du das sagst dann
machen wir das immer so verschwommen
immer ganz klar dahin nicht viel geiler
schon so jetzt haben sie ihren spaß
gehabt nach hause zu gefährlich ab nach
hause
hallo hab nach hause gibt sich zu sehen
so laufen wie bisher zufrieden ja wenn
sich die leute bisher mehr an gewisse
regeln halten würden wäre sogar noch das
sagen es ist ja so heutzutage ist ja der
zwei gegner so der edel mensch und der
drei gegner ist ja so ein bisschen deren
naja
crusoe fahrer laut verordnung ja vom
hamburger senat wo sie es stehen ja muss
die maske auf sein ja hinter der roten
linie
aber der kameramann steht ja er darf
ohne maske stehen okay das sind so die
sagen da kann ich verstehen
genau wie werden rauschgoldengel
jetzt bin ich hier mit dem kopf von hier
draußen mit dem ganzen verrückten leuten
hier und da etwas anderes hier hat die
besseren ja wo ist hier drin
der weihnachtsmann kann leider nicht zu
euch das geht leider nicht weil ihr seid
ihr im sommer bereich und da darf ich
nicht rein
was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist der
bürgermeister sagt wo man was ist und
was trinkt dann muss dann zweig sein
aber hier ist doch nix hier ist der
fußgänger rad- oder 3g oder
und deswegen wie wäre es wenn ich die
einfach kennzeichnet dass sie zweige
sind dass sie ihr eigener zweig bereiche
und verdanken sie das recht haben hier
auch ja schließt der weihnachtsmann wenn
sie das mal kurz halten können
können sie auch zurück ja darf ich sie
an ganz kurz zusammen ziehen
wenn man hat hier das drumherum war
schon sehr kurzen röcken jaja gibt mir
aber ist dass sicherheit geht vor das
ist es die dafür sind die zeiten zu
ernst es ist sicher egal was passiert
ich werde euch davon nicht da davon
wirklich was ich die ganze da wünsche
ich alles gute und
schlechte doch
alle jahre wieder kommt
corona
steckt uns allen
steckt uns alle an
ein spaß aber gleiche zu hause die gene
hause hersteller
versprochen was wartet auf euch zu hause
das zdf der zdf mit diesen schönen
worten getötet studio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]